i don't think china wants a war well
hold on hold on
keep it limited like it'll be like a
taiwanese let me let me let me pull that
story up to to set this set the stage
for this because we do have major
developments yeah from timcast.com
taiwan strengthening military to defend
against china during a speech on
taiwan's national day october 10th
taiwanese president xi ii
warned that the country would be
strengthening its military to defend
taiwan's sovereignty against the chinese
communist party saying
after taking complete control of hong
kong and suppressing democracy activists
the beijing authorities also shifted
away from the path of political and
economic development that they had
followed since reform and opening up
began decades ago at the same time
regional order is being challenged in
the south and east china seas the
routinelization of chinese military
activity in taiwan's southwestern air
defense identification zone at addis has
seriously affected both our national
security and aviation safety she
stressed that taiwan is willing to do
its part to contribute to the peaceful
development of the region and that
taiwan's position on cross-strait
relations remains the same neither our
goodwill nor our commitments will change
however psy explained that maintaining
peaceful relations requires china to
also maintain the peace she then said
that taiwan will continue to strengthen
its national defense to protect uh
protect its people from china
interestingly someone super chatted us
just a moment ago saying that it looks
like military is building up in
taiwanese streets yeah
so fighting his niece but um i know that
you were you were mentioning you had
experience in these areas yeah what do
you think's going on with this i mean is
we've been hearing over and over again
more and more stories they've been
saying that for a long long time and
that's one of the things that taiwan has
always been like this big big
you know focus for the united states for
a long time matter of fact the first
time that the united states ever
threatened to use a nucle and use
nuclear weapons against an enemy it was
like eisenhower back in the 50s like hey
well nokia and but one thing that's
interesting though is that one one thing
and this is open source i don't really
feel like you know we were talking about
it but right now is everyone talks about
an invasion a lot of folks might not
appreciate that one like the chinese
currently like don't have the sea lift
capability and it might not see it might
not seem like much but the thing is is
that you know one of the things they
teach you with you know all the big like
the fancy war colleges and all this
other stuff and all the big strategy
stuff is that you know they call it the
stopping power of water like it's really
hard to move an army across just i mean
look think about the massive undertaking
it took to just cross the english
channel yeah right i mean it it's a huge
deal like moving an army and you need an
army if you want to like actually
control something
about that well if you want to invade if
you want to seize hold and control
territory like you do need boots we're
going to stay there right and moving
that is just a massive undertaking so
they currently don't even have the sea
lift before you make it yeah or you or
you use uh sewing descent propaganda
cyber warfare that's a different story
right and if if the door gets opened
from the inside so to speak right and
they let them in that's that's a
different story but if you're talking
about like a confrontational
you know like them doing a d-day kind of
thing i don't think that's well but
let's let's be real that would be uh
that would at this point i think that
would be like saying you know if the if
if the chinese were gonna launch a
trebuchet at us it's like no no we don't
we don't need that ground invasion
anymore right they it's fourth and fifth
generation 100 percent yeah and they're
gonna economics manipulation propaganda
hollywood uh culture and we have to
understand multinational corporations
have sold this country out for pennies
on the dollar i mean the access that
they give them the the influence that
they give them john cena one of
america's most prominent celebrities is
like i'm sorry i'm so sorry for
recognizing a country during his tour
not even saying anything political it's
embarrassing now i definitely don't
think china wants to get into a hot war
yet i don't think they have the
resources especially the oil you need a
lot of oil especially if you have a navy
and there's going to be an energy crunch
soon that a lot of people are going to
wake up to and it's going to be very
difficult but also at the same time i'm
also thinking if you are china and you
have the failed leadership of joe biden
you have his actions of just how
horrible everything went in afghanistan
you must be thinking to yourself this is
the most perfect opportune time to do
something very aggressive because biden
is literally going to give us weapons
and he's going to give us
all the all the
information to all the people in that
area and he's going to give us all the
help that he can when we attack taiwan
because that that was his policy in
afghanistan it was blundered almost
deliberately so if you're trying to at
the same time you see a big opportunity
with the biden presidency or what if
this is just a distraction i mean
honestly we talked about it before the
long game ccp is really good at playing
the long game and in talking with people
in taiwan now generationally there's
differences we as americans tend to view
things black and white
we see taiwan as it's been for the last
you know 20 years as an example but the
new generations coming up have a lot
more in common with the general chinese
people than they do with their elders
necessarily they may not be opposed
becoming one with china and if you're
the ccp looking at the long game sure we
can do some positioning we can throw the
americans off
um but maybe the long game is truly just
waiting it out yeah because they don't
have to do their business it's not a
long game the war is now the the
conflicts happening right now they go
over willingly yeah you're right there's
like there's like 40 flights a day going
between taiwan and the mainland mainland
china you know it's great have you guys
ever been to china or like that i've
been to hong kong okay and i've been
there for a lot of yeah
yeah yeah yeah and they were the great
stuff you did by the way this was like
street warfare levels that i haven't
seen before comparatively maybe to the
yellow vest movement in france yep but
this was like gore blood and like
seriousness
if you go through the beijing airport or
the shanghai airport which is awesome
it's kind of funny almost it'll have an
english and that's like go the term like
the domestic terminal like within china
right and then the international
terminal right and then the
internationals every other country says
international flights
and hong kong and taiwan
because now it's like that's not
international you know yeah like that's
how they very much look at it and just
but i i really do i think you guys are
right you're right the war is being
fought now and i think you're also right
calling where where it comes down to
it's like look i think that the
generation i think they're going to open
the door from the inside and they're
just going to go over willingly and it
might not be you know this year might
not be this decade but you know it might
be soon and honestly that's the smart if
you're china that's the smart move
instead of like sending ships over and
kicking the door down yeah you don't
want to blow it up right what's the
value of taiwan is it the the
infrastructure and then the weather
they're importing stuff from mainland
china also national identity nationally
bannon said it was silicon valley west
okay they they produce so much of our
silicon chips we've got shortages now
and it's making it impossible to get
particularly cars so an invasion would
be bad because you'd end up destroying
infrastructure and that's what they want
is the infrastructure so that do they
have tunnels in taiwan is it like an
underground because that's what in in
vietnam the reason why we couldn't win
is because they had prepared tunnels for
like 2 decades before among other things
yeah uh i don't think as far as that
goes but the thing is i think they just
let them in willingly if they're in a
fight like if you think if you're china
that's a smart move right the only move
i can think of yeah otherwise you're
gonna have to blow up the thing you want
to take right exactly and hold them
under a police like nobody wants that
they don't want and look at they're good
at doing that guess what instead of like
shooting you you're like that we'll just
buy you off yeah i mean
africa that's not just africa exactly
about the exploitation in the united
states they're eating a lot of weakness
easily you can go to an american and
offer them cash we saw these professors
the thousand talents programs and then
they end up getting arrested because
they're effectively selling u.s research
to china yeah selling us out trump
canceled that program and biden vetoed
it when he got into office and
implemented it back again i'm like what
are you doing like how does this make
sense
and again everything's for purchase
everything has a price and the chinese
literally have a blank book they have
their own federal reserve system where
they literally print money out of thin
air they have a whole economic system
that's based out of just numbers that
they print on the screen so with that
kind of unlimited money they could do
anything they want and they're very
methodical especially with their belt
and road initiative especially with
their infrastructure now through
kazakhstan and afghanistan their
connections with iran and and the energy
that they get from them this is a very
methodical move that the chinese
understand is going to be a long term
but they understand that it started a
long time ago we're just realizing it
started they realized long time ago hey
we got to do this and they are like
they're playing 4d chess
and we're playing tic-tac-toe yeah it's
not even checkers yeah i think there's a
lot of individuals in the u.s i think a
lot of people who like you know watch
the show for instance probably know a
lot of this and have started taking the
individual actions to protect themselves
but without a strong collective like a
united states and a shared culture and
vision yeah we're getting we're getting
they're eating our lunch i think that's
british you play the long game you guys
ever get that vibe i don't know about
british monarchy they're like we don't
do they used to they're just sitting in
the road blocking traffic but saying
that they're not doing anything like i'm
not doing i think they used to i mean
and now that's like it's kind of like a
just a crappy like quasi-socialist
country it's really sad it's really sad
it's to me in my mind i've been to the
uk several times i just
yeah it's like oh wow this used to be so
amazing yeah but there's a lot of
problems too don't get me wrong i mean
you know colonialism
you know yeah that's what kind of
started all this taiwan was a british
colony yeah it was from the opium war
yeah they set up an operating taiwan
right
and that'll that allowed sanctuary for
the the chinese government when it was
taken over by communists to flee which
is my understanding yeah that's a big
one so technically you know i love that
meme of west taiwan you guys have seen
it oh yeah yeah the all of china
mainland is called west taiwan yeah
you know communism is
i think if communism succeeds and
expands and whatever whatever
whatever china is they find out
something clever it's not just about
doing communism it's about manipulating
the public giving them limited freedoms
so they can at least satiate themselves
but then
you use the iron fist for everything
else yeah it's a clever way to run
things the problem with soviet union is
you know books and tracking and stuff
one loaf of bread wasn't working they
weren't getting the supplies they needed
so china found a way to mix market you
know markets with the lower class and
then give themselves absolute authority
on top so all these businesses have a
chinese communist party branch or
whatever
that i think that will absolutely wipe
out humanity
so if you if
i know i mean
i missed what do you think is going to
wipe out humanity there chinese i think
if chinese style state communism or
whatever you want to call it succeeds in
becoming this global crypto communism
yes
this will wipe this will this will
decimate
probably the wrong choice of words
because the root is to reduce by ten
percent yeah but it would it would be a
catastrophe in that
central downer when he says oh
centralization of planning does not work
right it works in some areas like oh you
want to make cell phones great have a
have a plan like here's the parts we
need and you can organize it but you
can't organize for a billion people you
can't organize for a million people
properly it is the decentralized
um wisdom of the masses centralization
works if your centralized system is part
of a decentralized system so it's just a
big node exactly right so when we have
different businesses like the airline
knows the airlines and the dairy
industry knows the dairy industry that
makes sense it's a decentralized grid
but imagine having one government guy
who's like overseeing everything and
it's like dude you used to be a bus
driver and now you're trying to tell us
how to produce oil thanks maduro and the
country is not now they're what are they
doing they're doing a new currency in
venezuela oh it's it doesn't work one
person is not smart enough to run fifth
imagine someone thinking being so
arrogant they're like i am but one
person but i could i could be the ceo of
every fortune 500 company simultaneously
you'd be like that's insane you can't do
that the ceos barely do that but they
brought the smart people from the
universities don't worry they're
probably the university professor but
but if they dare sneeze in the wrong
direction of the communist party they
get sent to the work camps i mean look
what happened to alibaba look what
happened to so many entrepreneurs in
china that have been literally taken out
just for the smallest microaggression of
talking against the state and again this
shows you how bad this is another point
that we also have to entertain here
because with massive centralization
comes major problems that china is
dealing with right now including major
resource shortages they're trying to
make a desert into a fertile uh land of
of farming
because they know resource wise they're
screwed there's a lot of very
significant problems in china because of
the centralization and i think we also
have to examine that because they're not
as strong and as powerful with their
military um as they're trying to
convince the world because they have
very hard times even just making their
society run in some instances i imagine
that people hate the government there
just hate it well it depends they're
raised
as young children to love the stage to
obey the state and they know if they
dare even to criticize it they lose
privileges they lose the ability to send
their their children into good schools
they use they lose the ability to travel
they lose the ability to have good
internet because they criticized the
government or smoked a cigarette in the
wrong place or jaywalked so there's also
that aspect of it and consider how you
control people with tribalism so they're
raised to hate america as well to be
told that they're the bad ones they're
evil and then they cheer when they win
we're winning yay they're losing so that
makes people you know it boosts their
morale it makes them want to be
involved in that mob mentality
essentially i heard that there's like
chinese hero movies now where they're
fighting americans and the americans are
like how we had the russians in the 80s
oh wow
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you